hey everyone persia here and welcome to
the game pass show where we talk about
what's in what's out and which games
deserve a little bit more clout when it
comes to all things game pass we have a
few heavy hitters hitting the platform
this time around which is super cool so
leave a like subscribe and let's check
them out
i'm really excited about the games that
are hitting xbox game pass this time
around we've got humankind which is
available on pc
[Music]
we have need for speed heat which is
also available now on the cloud
star wars battlefront 2
also available on the cloud right now
star wars jedi fallen order is also
available now on the cloud
and coming on august 19th we've got
recompile
train sim world 2
12 minutes which we also have a really
cool interview with william defoe on our
website right now if you want to check
it out
why are you doing this
my father died of a heart attack
oh i
i i didn't have anything to do with
any second now he's gonna knock on that
door
help me this isn't happening this can't
be happening
psychonauts too
my name
is razz
and today
is my first official day on the job
and missed a very very popular game
can't wait to check it out for myself
because i've heard nothing but good
things about it as far as what's leaving
the platform on august 31st well you're
gonna have to say goodbye to blair witch
double kick heroes
nba 2k 21
and stranger things three the game
now for my favorite segment of this
episode what have i been playing
well to be very honest i've been playing
zoo tycoon
it's not a new game by any means it's
been out for quite a while but in the
middle of all these other games i'm
playing and other games that are a
little bit stressful it's nice to have a
game i can play and just relax with i
can feed some animals grow my zoo into a
massive empire collect all the
all the species and just having a nice
chill time it's super cute but it's also
really buggy but i think that adds a
little bit to the charm but one of my
favorite things about it is that you
obviously get this overhead view
of the park
just as any other tycoon but then you
can also go into like this third-person
view and run around the park and do
challenges that involve you running
around the park to raise certain animals
and take pictures it's really fun it's
really relaxing and i've been enjoying
it so that is what i have been playing
this week on xbox game pass
now it's time for our pick of the week
and my pick is going to be the master
chief collection the technical preview
the first one is over now and i guess
i've been feeling like i need to play
some more halos so having the master
chief collection has been super useful
we also have some really cool content on
the way for more halo stuff and being
able to hop back into all these old
versions have been super convenient
obviously halo 5 is not in the master
chief collection but i do have it on my
xbox and i've been able to hop into that
too but the master chief collection has
pretty much every other version so it's
been released make sure you like and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
every single xbox game pass update when
it happens hope you guys have a great
day and thank you so much for tuning in
see ya
[Music]